salut les loulous c'est matthieu
delormeau
mais elles sont douze jeunes prendre des
râteaux par hanouna sur des mythes
aujourd'hui dans tellement musclé on a
retrouvé la trace de bill du bigdil oui
cette ancienne légende de la télé
qu'est-il devenu
qui sa vie loin des projecteurs savez
vous planter des choux à la mode de chez
nous
nous l'avons retrouvé un document
exclusif pendant ce temps là pour moi
cuisses abdos fessiers
c'est dans la banlieue parisienne loin
des frasques de la jet set que nous
retrouvons bill qui nous reçoit chez lui
depuis la fin de l'émission l'ancien
acolyte de vincent lagaf a décidé de
s'éloigner des plateaux télé en quête
d'authenticité
les groupes humains attendaient devant
studio par couple aurait un petit bobo
après la trompait avec villa tirer
définitivement un trait sur cette époque
désormais il a décidé de se mettre au
service des autres et il est plus
heureux que j'aime quand même si ses
vieux réflexes reprennent parfois le
dessus
bonjour je cherche un prêt pour la tête
oui et j'hésite entre voler ou rideaux
leurs rideaux l'oni dont nous vivons et
après tant d'années villes gardent
encore un regard plein de tendresse sur
cette époque qui marquera à jamais ce f
voilà suis toujours proche de ramuntcho
a déjà fait et vous avez des nouvelles
de vincent lagaf
non mon ami vincent je me regarde je
vais te défoncer et même si les gens le
reconnaissent parfois encore dans la rue
pour leur bile a le regard tourné vers
l'avenir
il prépare son come back là j'ai croisé
sérieusement dans la rue il m'a même
proposé d'être chroniqueur dans tpm v
c'était il ya quatre ans j'attends qu'il
m'appelle
[Musique]
à